So at this point we have the majority of the
functionality of this application
so I'm going to show off some cool flutter
you can add since
Give it some more of that gamer gamification
if you will
I'll just show off how we can add different
things even though we might not want to keep
all of it
So it's actually throw another alert here so
we get our attack here
So once we have our hero attack let's say
What use are double Ambersons again so we'll
say if hero attackEquals zero.
Let's just returnThis alert here.
So anger
So far hero attack here is zero let's go
ahead and return an alert
And we'll use our anger Emoji here
And we'll say the code Works to say they're
missed so if he hits for zero
Well just essentially say that he missed
here
And it'll pop up this alert the only thing
with using alerts is they can get kind of
annoying
And let's show that off cuz you could
probably see what the health potions every
time an alert comes up
You do have to click it away it won't
continue
We'll definitely have more options later on
the course I'll make this a lot easierI'm
just trying to get a.
One intention I am getting really lucky with
potions
So there we get this the code Works to say
they're missedUp at the top.
And I think our potions is a little broken
right now we seem to be getting a lot of
potions
But you can see the more we add this is just
kind of for your own personal projects
if you want to add this to your projects
it's just a cool little things you can do
So I don't mind that one but let's go look
at our potion really quick
So we'll go to a role for Health it
Oh so right now I have if it's a less than
eight we need to make that if it's greater
than eightThere we go that'll fix that.
It's just a little things you will notice as
your bill not your projects
For getting how to do greater than or less
than can make something come across a hard
or really easy
And even for them like my villain here you
can do cool things
Just the same with their villain attack
Where you can say ifThe filling.
Attack is greater than or equal toWe'll say
12.
We can actually just give an alert as well
And we can actually let's use our string
interpolation as well againI mean say.
It's very busy faceCoding virus.
Hit us four and then we'llJust for and then
we'll just string interpolate that boss damn
or villain attack.
And then we'll just say that's a
criticalBlow. We'll put dizzy in there
again.
Or maybe exploding head
So we're saying if he hits us for a big
chunk of change will pretty much indicate
that that was a critical attack
And we can also have that pop up as well
So let's see if we can actually get that
critical blow to show up
Oh no I missedOof we get that the code Works
hit us for 14 a critical blow nice.
Oh and IJust realized a problem with this
application.
Right now I can actually use the potion as
many times as I want
And that's because when I drink my potion
I'm not sitting that fool back to false
So every time I drink a potion
I want to increase my healthSet it back 200.
I want to draw my health and then before I
actually end this let's go ahead and get my
hero and has health potion
And let's make that false nowSo now when I
refresh.
I will actually got a potionBut now since I
got another potion.
So I can drink my potion now but if I come
to drink it again
It's going to say I do not have a health
potion because that bull is now been flipped
back to falseAwesome.
So at this point the main functionality of
this app is made
And I always think it's important to
actually I'm going to be right back I'm
going to get some drink